What I hold in my hands right here is the perfect prospecting script and before we jump
into this because I want to talk about the breakdown I want to talk about the overview
of this script which we're going to be using but before we talk about that I want to tell
you how I came up with this script.
This is not something that I googled this is not something that was a swipe this is
not something that somebody gave me.
This right here that I hold in my hands is the product of me knocking thousands not hundreds
not tens thousands of doors door to door to door making thousands of prospecting calls
doing at this point I probably haven't made a thousand zoom closes at this point but we're
going to be there soon.
A lot okay this comes from experience this is not something that somebody gave me okay
so I want to tell you when I give you something I make sure it works first and I make sure
it works thousands of times so what I did is I took my knowledge of knocking on door
after door after door after making prospecting call after prospecting call after prospecting
call what worked what didn't work I put it into a document and that is the perfect the
perfect prospecting script okay so I want to give you the breakdown really quick it's
a really really simple I want to give you the outline of what it is then we're going
to jump into each individual step and I'm going to give you an actual example okay so
it's a really really easy process okay this this script is a really really easy four step
process with one at the end I guess you could consider a step but I want to go over those
steps really really quickly okay so here's what it is is we're going to it's four things
made up of four things number one is who you are and it's a pattern interrupt okay so these
are things that are going to happen during the prospecting script okay during the hook
who you are slash pattern interrupt and I'm going to explain this okay number two is what
you're doing why you're calling guys you need to give them a damn good reason why you're calling
okay you need to give them a damn good reason why you're calling them and interrupting their
day step three the deal what's in it for you and what's in it for them okay meaning what's
the win-win and by the way most people most salespeople to get this wrong and they focus
so much on what's in it for them hey you get this you get this you get this and they forget to tell
the business owner hey just so you know I'm gonna make money and a lot of it okay they're so scared
to do that and they forget to tell the business owner that the only thing the business owner is
thinking is what's the catch they like it they're in they're interested but they're thinking there's
got to be a catch there's got to be a catch he keeps telling me good good good good good what's
what's his motive okay so don't forget this part so what the deal so step three what is the deal
okay what's in it for them and what's in it for you and I would say it's more important to focus
on what's in it for you because they can clearly see what's in it for them step four is transition
and one thing that's going to really really help you guys in these calls specifically the the hook
process is your transitions okay there's times to pause there's times not to pause and we're
gonna work a lot on our transitions and once we deliver our pitch how we can seamlessly transition
okay so when I was doing door-to-door sales we would deliver the pitch and our transition had
to be fire if we didn't transition well slam door okay same exact thing you guys don't transition
well you're gonna get hung up on okay and then lastly we're gonna talk about the pullback which
is we're gonna talk about what that is when to use it how often to use it it's an actual secret
weapon so the overview guys just to recap one more time is this who you are slash pattern interrupt
okay number two what you're doing damn good reason why you're calling them number three
what is the deal okay what's in it for them what's in it for you step four transition and we're also
gonna talk about the pullback that is what makes up the perfect prospecting script guys and I do
want to share this there are people that have come through this program already that looked me in the
eye and said nick I am terrified of the phone you have no idea and I said oh I get it man I get it
no no you don't get it I won't even answer the the leads like this scares me this little piece
of metal piece of plastic it scares me I'm terrified and I've watched those same people
take this script take some hot leads that were coming in call a list of people who are already
sold on the product and turn it into thousands upon thousands of dollars per month so if you're
somebody that's sitting there going oh my gosh nick I'm scared welcome to the club okay everybody
is but when you have the script when you have the right list and you got hot leads it's a total
game changer let's go in